de fatima benomar militante et
cofondatrice de l'association les
effrontés elle est en direct avec nous
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce soir
quels sont les chiffres aujourd'hui 10
vg en france c'est s'agit-il
majoritairement d'avortement de détresse
comme le déclare
comment déclarer notamment les habits
les manifestants les manifestants pardon
et cet après midi n'ont absolument pas
les chiffres il reste stable sur depuis
des décennies a aidé puis la création du
droit à l'avortement auquel peuvent
avoir recours les femmes donc mais en
revanche effectivement on a toujours ses
3000 à 5000 femmes qui se retrouvent
chaque année en france à aller avorter à
l'étranger parce qu'elles dépassent les
léguer les délais légaux en france et
donc qu'ils vont avortée dans les pays
limitrophes comme la belgique ou
l'espagne qui ont des délais plus longs
qu'en france donc c'était important tout
simplement d'harmoniser ces délais et
effectivement nous on est pour que les
femmes puissent avoir recours à
l'avortement dans des conditions
sécurisées
c'est à dire que malheureusement en
france on a beaucoup fermer des centres
de diverger depuis qu'il ya eu la
restructurer les politiques de
restructuration de l'hôpital public qui
ont fait que beaucoup de petites
maternités de centres ivg ont de
proximité ont fermé et donc moi il ya
deux centres ivg plus la queue s'allonge
pour pouvoir avoir un rendez-vous pour
avorter plus il ya des femmes qui
risquent de dépasser ces délais tout
simplement
donc vous êtes favorable à ce texte qui
sera examiné au sénat et au sénat qui
prévoit l'allongement du délai d'accès
de l'avortement de douze à quatorze
semaines qui prévoit aussi la
suppression de la clause de conscience
en fait il y existe une clause de
conscience en france
1 le personnel de la santé a le droit de
refuser tout acte qui va contre sa
conscience
ce qu'il y avait en france était une
double clause de conscience spécifique
pour l'avortement
donc il ne servait à rien qu'ils
n'avaient que une existence on va dire
symbolique mais effectivement
ce que la loi exige que dans n'importe
quel centre médical il y au moins une
personne qui accepte de faire cet acte
mais la clause de conscience générale
existe si une personne ne veut pas
procéder à cet acte quel état des lieux
est ce que vous feriez de l'information
aujourd'hui en france concernant lé ivg
quand vous entendez les manifestants cet
après-midi évoqué la nécessité de
l'accompagnement des futures mères en
difficulté des aides sociales plus
nombreuses une meilleure connaissance de
la possibilité de recourir à
l'accouchement sous secret on a
l'impression que sa cible
un type de population en particulier
c'est la réalité aujourd'hui est ce que
ces femmes soient suffisamment informés
alors déjà je pense que ces collectifs
n'ont pas beaucoup de leçons à donner
quant à la qualité de l'information il
ya eu assez de happening ou même des
humoristes comme guillaume meurice qui
faisait des appels à ces centres qui
voyait qu'au contraire ces centres
d'information donc ils sont commandités
par les mouvements anti ivg données
exprès des mauvaises informations aux
femmes en leur disant qu'elle allait
devenir malade ou mourir etc avaient
recours à une ivg nous justement ce
qu'on veut ce sont des informations
fiables réel et ce qu'on veut c'est
vraiment mettre ça dans une politique
globale de maîtrise de ses droits
reproductifs c'est à dire effectivement
de l'information à l'école sur la
diversité des moyens de contraception
sur la formation sur l'éducation
sexuelle effectivement parce que plus
les femmes sont informés plus elles
maîtrisent leur fécondité plus elles
font des choix éclairés
est ce qu'on veut donc ce sont des cours
d'éducation contre les sexismes en
général pour le consentement pour contre
la culture du viol est entre autres
contre enfin pour les droits
reproductifs et qu'il y ait un accès
plus facile c'est vrai qu'en france on a
plutôt peu de choix par rapport aux
moyens contraceptifs pour les femmes ça
tourne beaucoup autour de la pile alors
que dans d'autres pays il ya une plus
d'informations il faut donc beaucoup de
plannings familiaux partout en france
accessible à tout le monde et une
information fiable et certainement pas
les faits qui news qui circule du fait
ces collectifs anti avortement le projet
de loi de bioéthique lui prévoit
d'autoriser en avortement pour des
treize psychosocial jusqu'en jusqu'au
neuvième mois alors on parle plus là
d'une interruption volontaire de
grossesse classique mais d'une
interruption médicale de grossesse ça
concerne qui précisément est ce que
c'est une avancée comment est ce que
vous considérez cette mesure en fait il
existe déjà une interruption médicale de
grossesse c'est-à-dire que
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et quand une femme décide de ne pas
mener à terme une grossesse
l'interdiction mais l'interruption
médicale de grossesse c'est quand elle
sa vie et celui de son enfant est en
danger et jusqu'au terme c'est à dire
imaginons je vous donne un cas une femme
en train d'accoucher est en danger elle
devient inconsciente et ben dans la loi
le médecin à ce moment là s'il doit
trancher entre la vie du bébé et la vie
de la mère c'est la vie de la mère qui
est supérieur donc jusqu'au terme
jusqu'au neuvième mois le médecin peut
décider que c'est l'enfant on va dire
qu'on sacrifie pour sauver la vie de la
merci en est dans cette situation là
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne de fatima
benomar militante cofondatrice de
l'association à les effrontés
[Musique]